we've talked about your earnings a
little bit here you were spot-on what
was forecast for your earnings per share
at 37 cents that's for the fourth corner
you beat a bit on revenues but take us
behind those numbers here's of a sense
not only of the vehicle sales but also
the profitability picture looking
backwards of the 2016 well when you look
at 2016 David we had a very strong
strong fourth quarter and strong
full-year and as you mentioned it's in
line with the guidance that we've given
and we actually had a number of second
best ever records we had our second best
ever adjusted full year company pre-tax
profit of ten point four billion dollars
an operating margin a very healthy
operating margin of 6.7% and our second
best cash flow at six point four billion
dollars and importantly behind that
peeling that back some of our region's
put in some really great performances
here in North America a margin for the
full year of nine point seven percent a
record profit in Europe our second best
ever profit in in China and also
all-time record sales so it was a very
very positive year for us and our cash
liquidity is strong and we distributed
over we distributed three and a half
billion dollars to our shareholders last
year so a very good year following a
record year that we had in 2015 so I'm
glad you mentioned that mix between the
United States North America and overseas
you have as you said record profits in
North America at the same time vehicle
sales are softening a bit are you
shifting in overall over toward Europe
and China I mean you were profitable in
Europe I think for the first time last
year well we're actually you know one of
our objectives as a company is to get a
better balance of profitability and as
we get into 2017 we do expect that the
you know our profits are going to be
continued to be strong but also at the
same time in Europe and in China we're
gonna continue our positive performance
there we do expect Europe to be down a
bit this year I get and that's based on
though the weakening of the Sterling
because it breaks it so I'm glad I'm
glad you mentioned 2017 let's take us
forward now because you're indicating to
dozens if you might be a little bit
softer i underst
and basically based on your new
initiatives that's autonomous vehicles
electric people's things like that tell
us about those plans and what they will
do to your bottom line well when we look
at 2017 we're gonna have another good
year at Ford it will be a bit down from
last year and the reason for that is
we're we're because we're investing in
emerging opportunities around
electrification autonomous vehicles and
mobility which will open up more growth
opportunities for us down the road so
we're investing for the medium in the
long term but still putting in a very
good year that we're projecting for 2017
so mark one of the things that you'll be
dealing with in 2017 is a new president
and as I mentioned already you've met
with him twice already he mentioned even
in the Roosevelt Room that second
meeting that he'd seen you twice in two
days so first of all just give us a
sense now as you've dealt with him as
president what sort of a person is he
going to be how is it gonna be to do
business with her what do you learn from
those meetings well I think the
president is going to be very good for
business in the economy and first and
foremost is because he's focusing on it
David I think it is very very positive
that his first couple of meetings in his
new administration under his new
presidency he was focusing on
manufacturing and automotive and he's
going to be very focused on driving
policies that will drive looking to
drive investment and job creation in
overall in American manufacturing and in
automotive manufacturing so I think it's
a very positive that he's focused on the
economy and he's listening and he's
understanding from our standpoint well
you know the suggestions that we have to
grow the economy going forward yeah and
one of the ways he wants to grow the
economy particularly the United States
is for you to invest more in plants in
the United States at the same time where
you are on this cycle because there is a
cycle to this vehicle sales isn't this
the worst possible time for Ford Motor
Company to be putting forward billions
of dollars in new capital investment in
manufacturing facilities in the United
States well let's put into perspective
you know our view is that the market
here in the US has plateaued but it's
it's plateaued or had a historically
high level and also when you look at the
segmentation in the marketplace people
moving from cars to trucks and SUVs that
plays to our strengths but we're going
to be very judicious we're going to
the right thing for the business earlier
this year we announced that we're gonna
invest another seven hundred million
dollars in our plant in Flat Rock
Michigan and also create 700 jobs we're
gonna be make sure we're doing the right
thing for the business understanding
where we are on the cycle we don't have
any plans to build any new plants but
clearly we want to continue to grow our
business and use the assets that we have
as best as possible
and if we have a good business
environment for manufacturing here in
the US that's one of the factors that we
look at in our investment decisions